since you live with a big group of cats
i assume your inner catologist is
tempted to make observations and
hypotheses about their behavior
and they about us can you share some of
them p.s
the cats may share the same about you if
they wish really you already
always jump at the punch line dude
i mean i find that kind of cool yeah
that is almost exactly what i said and i
sure hadn't seen it no you hadn't i
hadn't um
yeah so much right so much so what
there's i don't know we could come up
with a few things off the top of our
heads the one the one thing when i saw
that that i thought
um that i had been surprised at when i
noticed this and this is not from our
current crew of cats um
uh actually actually one of the cats
tesla um who is our it was our black cat
our eldest cat who will be 10 this year
um named after the dude not the car no
no the dude not the car um
when we had still had when we do still
have him
and um and pico and crenshaw who were
named after the
los angeles streets obviously um
they had a hierarchy
so i'm always fascinated by the
hierarchies that cats set up
um and two things about their hierarchy
were not as i would have expected if i
had been watching say wild baboons or
something one of which was
they seem to have different hierarchies
for different situations so
like displacement moves on the couch or
on someone's lap
a different cat would have different
priority
would be able to display someone whereas
at the food dish
um and i can't even remember at this
point probably crenshaw always had
primacy at the food dish
and one of the other two younger guys
had primacy
on laps but also in each of these
hierarchies where you could actually
watch it it was circular it wasn't
linear
and you know almost all of the work on
territoriality and hierarchy and
dominance hierarchies
um is well one is that you've got
separate male and female hierarchies
where you've got
a social situation such that you've got
multiple of both sexes
but they're almost always described as
linear and sometimes a little bit
recursive or like you inherit your
mother's
and so you can you can jump the line but
if we had three cats
you know a might be dominant to b b
dominant to c and c dominant to a
which sounds like it's not possible but
um it kind of was
all right the hypothesis i can't get
past which actually puts me in a tense
situation with other members of my
family is that
i believe the cats don't know
their names um and everyone else in my
family
is of the belief without the ability to
demonstrate it that they
react that they respond to their names
in some way that indicates recognition
i believe that one of our cats has no
understanding that names exist
and that one of our cats does
know his name and that the third cat the
the jury is somewhat out on that yes i
believe
that no domestic cat knows their name
and the domestic cat owners
would be shocked furthermore you think
that our dog knows the cat's names
yeah oh yeah the dog knows a lot that's
always up there no the dog
don't know where the dog is going but um
yeah
the dog never calls the cats by name but
she knows them and she knows her own
name but yeah now this
this this we're in agreement on yes
that's all you got okay okay we should
do a cat episode at some point we could
we could do that yeah
you